on 30 November 1965 members of the 170
third Airborne Brigade made an assault
landing on the outskirts of pouring lung
their mission was to seek out and
destroy any Vietcong in the area and
establish a perimeter defense post the
landing was made in a nearby rice field
immediately upon landing the troops
saddled up and moved out the men filed
quickly past the villagers to take up
their defense positions around the
perimeter of the community the entire
action was carried out without
difficulty
dense undergrowth was encountered on the
other side of the village and patrols
began moving out to search for any
Vietcong who may have been hiding in a
thick cover elsewhere the general move
up continued
meanwhile the commander and another
officer determined the most effective
deployment of the men in carrying out
their defense mission logistic support
for the mission commenced almost
immediately as the cargo helicopters
began arriving and offloading vehicles
ammunition and supplies in rapid
succession the big helicopters unloaded
and took to the air again overhead sky
Raiders appeared to recognize ur and
pinpoint any Viet Cong personnel in the
area but none were found and the men
settled in for their long vigil to deny
enemy access to phuong LOM
cavalry and infantry elements of the
first Brigade 100 and first airborne
division carried out a support mission
at been caught on 3 December 1965 here
seen rolling up highway 13 these units
were flown from their base camp at
fondren nearly 200 miles north to BN wah
airfield from the airfield they convoy
over the sniper infested road to the
first division camp at been cut their
mission was to serve as a reaction force
covering the first division sweeps of
the area some distance north of the been
cut camp
in the first division camp area both
units prepared for limited search and
clear operations the initial operations
to clear the vicinity of the camp got
underway with infantry forces scouring
the nearby terrain armed vehicles of the
cavalry took up strategic positions to
await any Viet Cong who might be flushed
into the open by the infantry sweep
action was limited to light enemy sniper
fire while the sweep and clean operation
was underway mortar teams and placed
their weapons and prepared to support
the action
alerted for a firing mission the mortar
crews gave their equipment a final check
and awaited the coordinates necessary to
show the suspected Vietcong position
though the firing continued for some
time there was no response from the
enemy in another phase of the mission
the men of the 100 first airborne
division were moved from the been cut
camp site to a nearby rubber plantation
gun jeeps covered the convoy as the long
line of vehicles moved out toward the
plantation in Viet Cong territory by the
time the convoy was nearing its
destination it was late in the day as
the vehicles arrived in one of the
plantation fields they were carefully
positioned and preparations were made to
spend the night in enemy territory
the hours of darkness however passed
without incident and the following
morning these units secured the position
and dug in
vehicles camouflaged with local greenery
and weapons ready the men waited in vain
for the enemy finally the cavalry units
were ordered back to their camp at been
cut throughout the entire operation only
minor sniper fire was reported
this sign announces the construction of
an office building in tent city be for
baker at tran salute a joint project of
an american and vietnamese construction
team the structure is an odd mixture of
a modern American design and primitive
methods of hand labor on 6 December 1965
a group of Vietnamese young and old
alike were carrying out cement work from
the mixing to the pouring everything was
done by hand
this included a rather unique windlass
system for lifting the heavy barrels of
cement to the second floor of the
building while at the same time lowering
an empty steel drum to the workers below
despite the limited lift capability of
the system it served the purpose
surprisingly well
the windless operators and the mixers
below kept the cement coming other
workers fill the wheelbarrow and carted
the mixture from the shaft to the work
site
the Masons poured and spread the
concrete for the new floor
the windless operators cranked away
without any visible signs of tiring even
in the United States a cement job this
size is something to be reckoned with
back on the ground the unusual work gang
of Vietnamese men women and youngsters
continued their labors with the crudest
of tools despite the very warm weather
they didn't seem to mind the job and
work progressed on tent city B's first
office building
at training the special forces are
carrying out a program of civic affairs
through this program special forces
units have financed the building of a
school a modern dispensary and have
repaired a vital road washed out during
the monsoon season this is the school
which was erected in the village of
trong soup on the outskirts of tiny
educating the young in Vietnam as
elsewhere is a difficult task due to
lack of facilities even this new school
building is incapable of handling the
numbers of students who wish to attend
there are three teachers classes are
divided so that half of the students
attend in the mornings and the other
half goes to afternoon sessions these
are first graders in class during the
morning session there were 72 of them
when this film was made on 8 December
1965
Vietnamese soldiers gave our chocolates
to the students and the Christmas candy
was eagerly accepted by the tots in the
nearby community of steering boy another
aid team of the Special Forces comes to
administer medical treatment to the
children these visits provide an
exciting event for the youngsters and a
welcome service for the parents at this
compound work is being completed on a
dispensary in order to provide the
villagers with continuing medical
attention
this is the dispensary as it appeared on
8 December 1965 the construction work
was still going forward but for the most
part the facility was almost completed
the dispensary is part of the civic
affairs program to improve the education
and health of the villagers
gifts of candy were donated by the
people of linesville Pennsylvania as
part of Operation Christmas star through
such gifts the medics gain the
confidence of the children and are able
to treat their ailments without fear on
the part of the child
a thorough job of bandaging is done to
prevent the spread of infection which
develops rapidly in these warm
temperatures various forms of fungi
infection are common in this climate
helping to cure these ailments with
modern drugs and teaching the villagers
how to safeguard their health is the
objective of this phase of the program
another civic affairs project of the
special forces units at Tynan was this
do-it-yourself ferry which was built and
placed into service at Ben soy in the
tiny area
as of nine December 1965 the river
crossing device was proving a boon to
civilians and the military alike
in the early morning hours of 14
December 1965 sentry dog handlers take
their canine charges for a training
session at a specially designed training
area in tan salute the animals are first
drilled for obedience to commands given
by voice hand signal and leash pressure
instant response to the handlers silent
command motions is a prime requisite for
these dogs orderly behavior on duty is
also essential
should the sentra dog be required to
pursue an elusive Prowler it must be
able to overcome all kinds of obstacles
while tracking and chasing the quarry to
build stamina and confidence in the
animals the handlers put them through a
rigorous obstacle course this phase of
the training also keeps the dogs anjal
and physically fit some of the obstacles
which these canine sentries easily leaf
would be difficult for a man to clear
another aspect of the training session
is to teach the dog to protect the
handler from sneak attack by an
assailant ranging in weight from 70 to
100 pounds these military dogs are a
formidable adversary for any would-be
attacker once released a sentry dog
quickly levels the intruder and holds
him prisoner
along the road to futo ha Jardin
Vietnamese orphans wave their flags to
celebrate the building of a new
orphanage the date is 12 December 1965
and the Vietnamese honor guard salutes
the arriving members of the US Army
Signal Corps whose financial
contribution made the new orphanage
possible as in all ceremonies of this
kind there were speeches to thank the US
servicemen and the all-girl choral
society performed as the assembled
dignitaries looked on for some 50
children this day's groundbreaking
ceremonies would never be forgotten even
the government in Saigon took notice of
the occasion and sent a special envoy to
officiate on behalf of the people at
last the solemn moment arrived when it
was time to lay the cornerstone and the
Saigon representatives step forward to
do the honors when the cornerstone have
been set in place the civilian and
military dignitaries returned to the
platform and the smallest orphans sang
for them with their gift of $3,000 the
Army Signal men had created a new home
for these unfortunate boys and girls
as the ceremony's came to a conclusion
the commemorative book was signed by the
officials and another civic action was
complete
in cooperation with the Civil Affairs
support command Aetna trung medical
officers of the Army and Air Force
conducted a sanitation evaluation
mission on 7 December 1965 purpose of
the investigation was to locate possible
sources of contamination and breeding
places for disease bearing insects an
exposed and unsanitary hotel kitchen was
spotted by the investigators and through
civil affairs support command listed for
cleanup other sanitation hazards were
located at the same site such as these
partially empty bottles and cans
fermented liquids and stagnating sewage
water our principal breeding places for
germs and disease bearing mosquitoes
after a thorough inspection the
researchers wrote up their reports and
moved on to continue their work through
such investigations as this sanitation
work is moving forward
at Qumran Bay one of South Vietnam
seaports the US Army Corps of Engineers
is installing a deal on floating pier
this mammoth pier is capable of
providing dockage for several
ocean-going vessels at once the floating
pier which is an engineering marvel was
first towed into the desired position
all heavy equipment needed to accomplish
installation such as this 70 ton crane
was placed aboard
other material for the job is delivered
by LCM motorized barges when finally
installed the pier will rest upon huge
steel pipe pilings called caissons the
pier itself is constructed with holes
for the caissons to pass through on 9
December 1965 the pier was in the
desired position and several of its case
on pilings were already in shown here is
the crane working with one of the
caissons after the great pipe leg is
lowered through its position hole in the
pier it comes to rest on the floor of
the bay however there is still a great
length of the case on rising above the
pier sticking up through the hole as
each case on is lowered into position a
permanent jack is placed around it the
jacks are then used to shinny the pier
up the caissons until it is in the
desired attitude above the water here we
see the crane moving a case on with Jack
attached into position for insertion
into its guide port
as the excess caisson lengths were cut
off and removed each remaining deck stub
had to be capped off when the crane had
lowered the cap to within inches of its
position the work crews had to make sure
it would seat properly otherwise the
bolt holes would not line up guiding and
moving the heavy caps is not an easy
task and it took quite some time before
the crew supervisor was satisfied and
allowed it to be lowered and bolted into
place
by the time one case on and Jack had
been capped off another piece of case on
at another location was ready for
removal the crane was then hooked up
with the case on section and it was
carefully removed
welders go to work shortly thereafter
and neatly seem the cutoff stub to the
cap acceptance collar
securing bolts are welded to each Jack
these are the bolts which will fasten
the jack to the deck of the pier
from the nearby barge the entire case on
assembly and how it functions could be
plainly seen the busiest man on the job
was the crane operator here he is seen
tipping over one of the massive case on
sections as he gets it ready for removal
from the pier just clearing away pieces
of case on was a chore in itself
checking on the welders again they were
busy trimming up the stub from a last
cut which has left a jagged edge unless
this procedure was followed it would
have made the capping operation
difficult
to hold down the caps outsized votes
were used and these were finally snugged
down with great construction wrenches
cameran Bay have gotten its new here
you